[Music]
[Applause]
ryan carchi covers usc for the la times
kind enough to join us on uh what has to
be a busy day uh probably busy a couple
of days coming up here
uh why now why was clay helton fired
after uh two games
you know i think it was just made pretty
clear in that that stanford defeat when
you're down by more than four touchdowns
in the fourth quarter to a a 17 you're
supposed to be a 17 point favorite uh
it was the most lopsided loss at the
coliseum to an unranked opponent since
2000
so it and i think just the general vibe
around the program just the the
frustration of this fan base there are
very few fan bases i think that spend
three years just completely resolute in
the fact that their coach should be
fired and and letting the administration
know very clearly so i think that was
in their heads of course and i think
they just realized that after
putting behind clay held putting so many
resources and retooling the staff and
changing the recruiting behind clay
helton to see him come out with just a
demoralizing loss that basically showed
all of the same issues in the last
several years i think that was just kind
of a breaking point for them
what were the expectations for this team
well the the expectations as they said
it have always been to get to a pac-12
championship or to win a pac-12
championship and you know
i think it was just pretty clear in that
game that they weren't going to do that
but now you know it was clear from the
statement that mike bone the athletic
director put out
yesterday that it's kind of a national
championship or bust attitude as they
look for a head coach and
you know they're saying all the right
things
in that sense but
you know i think with clay hilton the
result or
the fact of the matter was he was just
never going to reach that point and i i
think you know this administration came
to that realization maybe a little bit
later than some other people did i think
that there's it's fair to quibble with
the fact that they didn't just take care
of this last year but there are other
factors involved namely his buyout for
for a long time just given the fact that
lin swan had given an extension to clay
helden after the 2017 season uh if they
would have fired him in 2019 it would
have been 20 million dollars of a buyout
so
that certainly played a part uh that
buyout's much smaller now so
i think that certainly helps but at a
certain point you just reach that point
where fans just aren't going to show up
and it's going to affect you financially
in that way too
yeah and you go five and one you know
during the pandemic and you can't fire
him then but i was just surprised and
your new athletic director when he came
in at least was fair and you would want
that in your athletic director to say
let me just see what we have here to be
fair
to uh to clay helton
i was just surprised that lynn swann
um kept him
right
that was certainly a sign of the fact
that lin swan didn't necessarily have
the athletic director experience that
you need when you're at usc and since
he's left it's been kind of clear even
just talking to officials in the
athletic department who were there for
both that it's just a stark change in
professionalism for whatever you think
about the football program uh at least
mike bone has you know
quite a bit of experience when it comes
to the administrative aspects of the job
and you know
this will be the toughest test of him
being an athletic director and uh it'll
be interesting certainly to see how that
search plays out
but ryan you have so much that's gone on
at usc in the last couple of years we
have the
you know operation varsity blues you
have a you know a
sexual assault uh harassment lawsuit
against a campus doctor i mean you
didn't have fans at the football games
there's a whole lot going on here it
almost felt like they couldn't make a
move like this because they didn't want
to add to what was already going on
would that be overstating this
uh
maybe just some degree although i do
think like all of those things play a
factor obviously and i i think
you know
it's an interesting sign of where the
university is that at that
the leadership of the university looks
at the pandemic
and the obvious deficit and financial
issues that come from that and they say
you know we still need to get rid of
clay help
whether his buyout is over 10 million
whether we're going to have to pay you
know several million more to buy out to
members of his staff or to buy out a new
coach
uh at a certain point the bottom line
that's being affected uh by our football
program uh is important enough to make
that change but i do think you know with
clay helden it always helped the fact
that he was you know viewed as a man of
integrity he was a consummate gentleman
you never had to worry about
uh just ethical issues at least at a
program level uh with clay helton in
charge and that was the reason why he
was hired in the first place by pat
hayden uh you know post steve sarkeesian
uh pat hayden kind of became taken with
the fact that you know this was a man of
integrity who would be leading us into a
new era we can put
this sarkeesian era behind us
obviously a pretty short-sighted look at
how you hire your football coach
and that certainly played out but i
think that when you look at the fact
that clay helton got six full seasons
as the head coach i think it helped
quite a bit that he was kind of viewed
as a man of integrity and people
generally liked him including his
players
who should be the next head coach at usc
you know that
that's a tough question i i think they
have a really difficult search ahead in
the sense that a lot of boosters want a
big splash higher our own bill plaschke
said in his column yesterday that you
know they need to go out and hire a guy
not that need still needs to prove
himself but that has already proven
himself that already has the equity in
recruiting and nationally uh to sort of
instantly hit the ground running and
make usc that national contender i'm not
sure many of those guys are out there
there's a bob supes maybe a chris
peterson i know you know i'm sure in the
coming weeks
their agents will will leak out that
they're not interested um the obvious
choice a lot of people have connected is
luke fickle at cincinnati because that's
who mike bone hired when he was the
athletic director there
i'm not so sure that's a sure thing i
think luke fickle uh you know spent
basically his entire life in ohio and
the midwest um i've heard from some
people they're not sure whether he would
want to go to usc and be a part of that
kind of la cacophony of fans constantly
complaining about the program now
there are a lot of other candidates matt
campbell maybe even a bill o'brien who
sort of bring that heft maybe they have
kind of proven themselves a little bit
in difficult places what about urban
meyer
i was wondering if you'd bring that up
uh that i'm sure there will be a lot of
message board uh topics with urban meyer
in the title
over the next couple weeks but the same
issues stand from before when when he
was talked about and every indication
that i gotten from usc officials from
people at the university even not even
just in athletics was just the appetite
for risk yeah
bringing in a guy who has
maybe
questions about his integrity in his
past
you know at this current moment in our
society i just don't know that the that
administration at the university level
has the stomach for that lane kiffin
that would certainly be interesting
i don't know if lane would want to come
back just given the way uh the way
things ended but
honestly everything i've heard is that
they will open up the search to anyone
and everyone for now they have basically
three months to conduct it so that's a
lot of time to figure it out but it also
leaves less margin for error in terms of
if you get it wrong you really screwed
this up
i'm gonna throw out another name
and he was just on campus
david shaw yes
i mean
he wouldn't leave for nfl jobs now i i
wonder if he'd really want to uproot his
family and all that to leave stanford
when he clearly i mean
they've had a rough couple seasons and
you don't hear his name anywhere near
the hot seat so
i think that's a pretty comfortable
situation to be in although
fascinating idea
great to talk to you ryan thanks for
joining us we'll be following what uh
what you write
awesome thanks that's ryan cartier he uh
covers usc for the la times